>> GREG PALKOT LIVE IN SEOUL.
ONE HOUR LATER.
THANKS.
>>> LET'S TALK MORE ABOUT THE
REGIONAL EXPECTATIONS FOR THIS
SUMMIT.
JOINING ME HERE IN SINGAPORE,
SEOUL BUREAU CHIEF FOR THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL" AND WHITE HOUSE
CORRESPONDENT FOR THE DAILY
MAIL.
I WANT TO TALK FIRST ABOUT WHAT
THE EXPECTATIONS ARE WHEN THE
DEFINITION BOTH SIDES MAY LOOK
TO FOR DENUCLEARIZATION.
HEADING IN, JONATHAN, WHAT DO
YOU THINK?
>> WELL, LOOK, THIS HAS BEEN THE
TOP TOPIC FOR THE PAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS.
WHAT'S STRIKING HERE IS THAT WE
STILL DON'T HAVE A COMPLETELY
SORT OF ONE TO ONE UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT EXACTLY IS MEANT BY
DENUCLEARIZATION.
NORTH KOREA TALKS ABOUT THE
COMPLETE DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
KOREAN PENINSULA.
DONALD TRUMP HAS TALKED ABOUT
AND THE U.S. POSITION HAS BEEN
FOR COMPLETE VERIFIABLE
IRREVERSIBLE DENUCLEARIZATION.
WE COULD TALK ABOUT THE VARIOUS
DIFFERENCES BETWEEN THE TWO OF
THEM.
THERE ARE GAPS STILL.
IT IS UNCLEAR WHETHER OR NOT
THEY HAVE BEEN BRIDGED IN THE
MEANTIME BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD A
LOT OF SHUTTLE DI PLO MA SI TAKE
PLACE -- DIPLOMACY TAKING PLACE
THE LAST COUPLE OF WEEKS.
WE JUST DON'T KNOW AND WE MAY
NOT KNOW UNTIL TUESDAY.
>> IT'S AMAZING, IT IS A DIRECT
RESULT OF THE MAXIMUM PRESSURE
CAMPAIGN.
THE ONLY REASON NORTH KOREA IS
SITTING DOWN AT THE TABLE WITH
TRUMP IS THAT THEY BELIEVE FOR
THE FIRST TIME THAT THEY'VE GOT
SOMEBODY IN THE WHITE HOUSE THEY
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH, AND
THEIR NUCLEAR MISSILE PROGRAM,
NOT CONTAIN IT, AND I THINK HE'S
GOT NORTH KOREA AND CHINA'S
ATTENTION.
>> CERTAINLY KIM WANTS THE
PHOTOGRAPHS OF HIM SHAKING HANDS
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP BECAUSE
THAT'S LEGITIMATE AND EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT THAT MEANS HE
SOLIDIFIES HIS RULE AT HOME.
WE WILL SEE THOSE PICTURES OF
TRUMP AND KIM FOR DECADES IN
NORTH KOREA.
SO YOU KNOW, PRESIDENT TRUMP
GIVES UP A LOT OF LEVERAGE AS
SOON AS HE SHAKES HANDS WITH
KIM.
>> TO GORDON'S POINT THERE AT
THE END, AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS SUMMIT, KIM GETS ONE OF THE
BIG THINGS HE WANTS WHICH IS
THIS PICTURE
>> RIGHT, SPEAKING TO WHAT
LINDSAY GRAHAM ALSO SAID LATER
ON, IT'S PEACE OR WAR.
HE THINKS THOSE ARE THE TWO
OPTIONS POTENTIALLY COMING OUT
OF THIS, IF PRESIDENT TRUMP
DOESN'T EVENTUALLY GET A DEAL
WITH NORTH KOREA TO
DENUCLEARIZE.
HE SAID WE COULD TALK FOR DAYS
ABOUT THE DEFINITION OF THAT.
THAT'S WHAT WE HOPE TO DO TO
TALK DAYS FOR THAT.
YOU HAD MIKE POMPEO REFUSING TO
TELL REPORTERS AT THE WHITE
HOUSE LAST WEEK HOW CLOSER THEY
HAD GOTTEN ON THAT.
HE SAID THEY HAD ON THE
DEFINITION BUT WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH CLOSER.
I HAVE EXPERTS TELLING ME THAT
NORTH KOREA DOESN'T JUST
CONSIDER DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
PENINSULA, THAT THEY COULD
EXPECT THAT TO EXTEND TO OUR
MILITARY PRESENCE IN GUAM.
THAT'S A QUESTION AS TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE U.S. IS
PREPARED TO OFFER THAT.
>> I WANT TO READ SOMETHING FROM
RICHARD HOSS AFTER THE G-7 BACK
AND FORTH AND WHAT ENDED UP
HAPPENING THERE.
THE UNRAVELLING OF THE G-7
SUMMIT WORKS IN NORTH KOREA'S
FAVOR, HE WRITES, AS PRESIDENT
TRUMP WILL NOT WANT TO BUST UP
TWO SUMMITS IN A ROW, LEST
PEOPLE CONCLUDE HE IS THE
PROBLEM.
INCREASES INCENTIVE FOR KIM TO
UP HIS ASKS AND LIMIT HIS
COMPROMISES AND FOR TRUMP TO DO
THE OPPOSITE, HARDLY THE IDEAL
CONTEXT.
JONATHAN, COULDN'T SOMEBODY LOOK
AT THAT AND SAY COULDN'T IT BE
THE EXACT OPPOSITE, THAT HE'S
WILLING TO JUST GET UP FROM THE
TABLE AND SAY THIS ISN'T GOING
TO WORK AND WALK AWAY?
>> WELL, LOOK, I THINK THERE'S A
CASE TO BE MADE THAT KIM CAN WIN
EITHER WAY.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY HE GETS
EVERYTHING THAT HE WANTS IF HE
MAKES A BIG ASK AND GETS IT.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY GOOD FOR HIM.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
THERE IS A POSSIBILITY THAT EVEN
IF THINGS DON'T GO WELL -- GO
WELL, HE SAID LOOK I ACTED IN
GOOD FAITH I HANDED OVER THE
DETAINEES, I BLEW UP THE SITE,
I'VE BEEN HONEST.
>> YOU HAVE TO ADMIT THE
HOSTAGES COMING BACK, NORTH
KOREA AT THE TABLE, THE PARADIGM
HAS SHIFTED, SOMETHING CHANGED
FROM ALL THE SIX PARTY TALKS
EFFORTS BEFORE TO GET TO THIS
POINT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS THAT
WOULD BE HIM.
IT'S BECAUSE HE'S HERE NOW AND
THE NORTH KOREANS UNDERSTAND
THAT HE'S NOT PLAYING AROUND.
AND IT COULD GO THE OPPOSITE
WAY.
IF HE FEELS THAT THEY ARE NOT
SERIOUS, HE SAID, WITHIN THE
FIRST MINUTE OF SITTING DOWN, HE
WILL GET UP AND WALK AWAY.
THAT'S ACTUALLY AN OPPORTUNITY
POTENTIALLY FOR THE PRESIDENT TO
SHOW HIS STRENGTH HERE AND TO
SHOW NOT JUST TO KIM JONG-UN BUT
ALSO JUSTIN TRUDEAU THE PRIME
MINISTER OF CANADA THAT WHEN THE
U.S. IS PUSHED, THAT HE WILL
PUSH BACK.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING WE HEARD
LARRY KUDLOW THE ECONOMIC
ADVISOR TO THE PRESIDENT SAY
THIS MORNING TOO.
THAT THEY FEEL THAT TRUDEAU IS
TRYING TO EMBARRASS PRESIDENT
TRUMP ON THE EVE OF THIS
HISTORIC SUMMIT.
AND THAT THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
LET THAT HAPPEN.
>> WE JUST HEARD FROM GREG
PALKOT IN SEOUL.
OBVIOUSLY SEOUL IS WATCHING ALL
OF THIS VERY CLOSELY.
AT ONE POINT THEY WANTED TO BE
AT THE TABLE.
BUT THAT FIRST MEETING IS JUST
TRANSLATORS AND THE TWO LEADERS.
WHAT IS SEOUL LOOKING AT?
HOW CONCERNED ARE THEY ABOUT
WHAT COMES OUT OF THIS?
>> WELL, THEY ARE CONCERNED BUT
THEY ARE ALSO VERY HOPEFUL.
KEEP IN MIND THE PRESIDENT OF
SOUTH KOREA HAS INVESTED A GREAT
DEAL IN THIS WHOLE PROCESS.
HE'S BEEN THE ONE KEEPING THINGS
ON TRACK EVEN THOUGH WHEN IT
LOOKED LIKE THINGS WERE GOING
OFF THE RAILS IN ONE DIRECTION
OR THE OTHER.
I THINK HE UNDERSTANDS
INHERENTLY THAT DONALD TRUMP,
WITH KIM JONG-UN, OFF VOLATILE
MIX HERE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO
COME OUT OF TUESDAY.
I THINK PEOPLE IN SEOUL ARE
DEFINITELY CROSSING THEIR